regardons la situation suivante
on a comme la dernière fois une voiture
qui se dirige vers un observateur
à une certaine vitesse v
et l'observateur située un peu plus loin
reçoit une onde lumineuse qui aimait la
voiture
et notre but ça va être de déterminer la
fréquence que mesure l'observateur la
fréquence de l'undd telle qu'elle est
mesurée par l'observateur en fonction de
la fréquence telle qu'elle a été émise
par la voiture
mais cette fois ci on a une onde
lumineuse est pas une onde classiques
comme une onde sonore c'est à dire que
l'undd ne se propage pas dans un milieu
il n'y a pas de référentiel absolue dans
lequel étudier la propagation de l'aude
et en particulier on sait d'après la
relativité restreinte que la lumière se
déplace toujours dans tous les
référentiels inertielle à la même
vitesse la vitesse de la lumière c'est
en particulier on peut toujours choisir
un référentiel dans lequel l'observateur
est immobile donc ça c'est une première
différence avec le cas classique pour
les ondes sonores dans le cas des ondes
sonores il est important de prendre en
compte la vitesse de l'observateur parce
qu'on a un référentiel absolue qui est
fixé par l'air dans lequel se propage
l'ondh
mais ici en relativité avec la lumière
le mouvement la propagation de la
lumière est toujours la même quel que
soit le référentiel est donc sans perte
de généralités on peut choisir le
référentiel dans lequel l'observateur et
immobilier
alors pour commencer on va tracer deux
axes un axe x qui sera lax des espaces
et un axe t qui sera lax du temps et
cette grille ici xt forment ce qu'on
appelle l'espace temps
alors notre observateur est ici et il
reste immobile dans son référentiel
c'est à dire qu'à chaque instant
l'observateur garde une même position
suivant lac 6 donc ici c'est la position
de l'observateur qui ne varie pas au
cours du temps
la voiture quant à elle se situe un peu
plus loin ici par exemple
et par contre la voiture est en
mouvement c'est à dire qu'à un instant
suivant elle se déplace elle est
légèrement plus à droite et ainsi de
suite
alors je vais pas dessiner ses
différentes voitures successives
mais je vais simplement représenter le
mouvement de la voiture par un vecteur
dont l'inclinaison ici représente sa
vitesse si la voiture se déplaçait plus
vite son inclinaison serait plus
importante
enfin le dernier élément du problème
c'est l'ondé lumineuse qui est émise par
la voiture
et qui se propage dans l'espace temps
avec une vitesse plus importante donc
une pente plus incliné que la voiture
qui est la vitesse de la lumière
donc si je résume l'observateur se
déplace dans cette direction suivant la
kz temporel la voiture se déplace dans
cette direction un peu incliné et l'ong
lumineuse se propage selon une direction
encore plus incliné qui correspond à la
vitesse de la lumière
la première étape ça va être d'essayer
de décrire ces trois vecteurs ici par
des coordonnées alors on a le système de
coordonnées thé xx et on va pouvoir
écrire ses vecteurs dans ses systèmes de
coordonner on va d'abord commencer par
leur donner un nom le vecteur de
l'observateur va l'appeler eu
le vecteur de la voiture on va l'appeler
v
est le vecteur de l'ong lumineuse on va
l'appeler cas
ce qui est standard pour parler d'un
vecteur d'onde
on va utiliser ici une convention qui
est assez standard qui est de
représenter t comme étant la première
coordonnées en eau et x comme étant la
deuxième coordonnées en bas du vecteur
alors le vecteur eu ici on voit
simplement que c'est un vecteur
verticale dirigée uniquement le long de
la direction t et donc on peut le noter
1 0 par exemple on aurait pu noter 2 0
ce serait un vecteur deux fois plus
grand
ici la norme du vecteur ne nous
importent pas trop ce qui compte c'est
surtout son orientation son inclinaison
qui indique sa vitesse dans
l'espace-temps
la vitesse de la voiture quant à elle
peut être noté un
v6 on considère que cette distance ici
correspond à une unité de temps alors la
distance parcourue par la voiture donc
la composante spatiale du vecteur c'est
la distance égale vitesse fois temps
donc c'est la vitesse de la voiture x 1
et donc c'est vrai
en particulier si la vitesse de la
voiture est plus élevé la composante
spatiale du vecteur ici est plus
importante
et pour finir le vecteur d'onde de l'ong
lumineuse est donnée par un c où cette
fois ci on a simplement utilisé la même
forme qui s'y met avec la vitesse de la
lumière
la dernière chose qu'il va nous falloir
faire c'est de comprendre comment à
partir de ces trois vecteurs on peut
donner l'expression de la fréquence
telle qu'elle est reçu par l'observateur
et de la fréquence telle qu'elle est
émise par la voiture
pour bien comprendre ici ce qui est ce
qu'on va faire par la suite il est
important de comprendre fondamentalement
ce que représente la fréquence du monde
alors la fréquence du monde c'est
simplement le nombre d'oscillations
qu'on compte en une unité de temps
donc notre observateur va regarder londe
vibrer et en une unité de temps l'undd
va vibrer un certain nombre de fois et
c'est ce nombre de fois qu'on appelle la
fréquence
alors on a vu que le vecteur d'onde de
l'undd qu'on avait appelé cas
représente en fait le nombre de fois que
l'undd oscille dans l'espace temps si le
vecteur d'onde est deux fois plus grand
ça signifie qu'on a deux fois plus
docile à sion le long de ce vecteur
est donc ce qui va compter ce qui va
mesurer la fréquence de l'ondh
c'est la projection de ce vecteur cas
sur l' axe temporel parce que en
projetant ce vecteur
on peut compter le nombre de fois que
l'undd oscillent en une unité de temps
et ça c'est vraiment la fréquence donc
imaginons qu'on dispose d'un vecteur
dont on ne connaît pas la norme mais on
sait que ce vecteur est orientée selon
la direction du temps appelons le eu
ce qu'on veut calculer c'est la
projection du vecteur cas dans la
direction du vecteur eu et pour calculer
la projection d'un vecteur sur un autre
ce qu'on utilise c'est le produit
scalaires
cas point eut donc le produit ce cas
l'erc a point eu c'est la projection du
vecteur cas sur le vecteur eu
alors ici on a une petite subtilité
c'est que si le vecteur u est multiplié
par deux par exemple le produit
scalaires est également multiplié par
deux nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
uniquement la projection du vecteur cas
dans cette direction la norme du vecteur
u ne nous intéresse pas et donc ici on
va diviser par la norme du vecteur eu
cette grandeur ici c'est le nombre de
fois que l'undd oscillent en une unité
de temps quand on mesure le temps le
long de cet axe dirigé par le vecteur eu
et donc ça c'est la fréquence mesuré
selon l' axe du temps qui est définie
par bus
fermons la parenthèse et revenons à
notre situation
ici on peut donc écrire que la fréquence
telle qu'elle est mesurée par
l'observateur fr elle est donnée par le
produit scalaires entre le vecteur eu
donc le vecteur qui correspond à l axe
temporel de l'observateur cet axe t
est le vecteur d'onde cas le tout divisé
par la norme du vecteur eu
ça c'est la projection du vecteur d'onde
sur l'axé temporel de l'observateur
maintenant dans le cas de la voiture
il faut connaître l' axe temporel de la
voiture et cette fois-ci laxiste encore
ailes de la voiture ça n'est pas
l'accepter ça c'est l' axe temporel de
l'observateur la voiture dans son
référentiel a l'impression d'être
immobile et donc son axe temporel c'est
cet axe aussi ses lacs ce qui est dirigé
selon son mouvement dans l'espace temps
ces lacs ce qui est dirigé selon le
vecteur v et donc pour la voiture la
fréquence de l'ondh c'est son vecteur à
élever produits scalaires le vecteur cas
/ la norme du vecteur v
et on voit ici toute la l'élégante
géométrique de la relativité la
fréquence c'est simplement la projection
du vecteur d'onde sur chacun des deux
axes temporel à partir de là on a
quasiment terminé notre calcul la seule
chose qu'il reste à faire c'est de
déterminer les produits scalaires et les
normes entre ces vecteurs
et pour faire ça c'est là qu'entre en
jeu toute la bizarrerie de la relativité
restreinte c'est ce qu'on appelle la
métrique de minkowski
alors vous avez peut-être déjà vu que le
produit scalaires entre deux vecteurs ab
et disons alfa beta
c'est définis dans le plan comme à foix
alpha le produit des composantes ici
selon eex plus défaut à bêta le produit
des composantes selon y
est du coup la norme d'un vecteur qu'on
peut noter ab
est donné par la racine carrée du
produit scalaires de ab avec lui-même
ce qui fait la racine carrée de à foix a
donc à au carré plus bo carré
et ça on appelle ça plus généralement le
théorème de pythagore en fait le
théorème de pythagore ça dis simplement
que la norme d'un vecteur peut être
calculé en faisant la racine carrée de
son produit scalaires avec lui-même
il trouve qu'en relativité le produit
scalaires et la norme ne sont pas
définies de cette façon donc le théorème
de pythagore en particulier fo en
relativité
alors pour déterminer le produit
scalaires de deux vecteurs dans l'espace
temps ici on va rajouter 1 c'est carré
donc cesser la vitesse de la lumière est
ici au lieu d'avoir un plus on va avoir
un mois ce signe - c'est vraiment ce qui
crée toute l'étrangeté de la métrique de
brink of ce qui est donc de l'espace
temps
et cette façon de calculer un produit
scalaires c'est ce qu'on appelle la
métrique
de minkowski
c'est vraiment la base de toute la
relativité restreinte
alors vous voyez que du coup en
modifiant l'expression du produit
scalaires l'expression de la norme est
elle aussi modifiée ici on assez carrée
qui apparaît est ici le plus se
transforme en moins
bon et bien maintenant qu'on a ces
expressions la métrique de nicox qui on
va pouvoir finalement exprimé ses
produits scolaires et ses normes et donc
terminer notre calcul
commençons par calculer la norme du
vecteur but
on a vu que le vecteur us écrivait 1 0
et donc en particulier sa norme
se détermine avec la métrique de
lynkowski ici c'est la racine carrée de
ces carrés
fois un au carré qui donne un - b au
carré et b ici vos héros donc c'est
simplement la racine carrée de ces
carrés ce qui donne c'est
maintenant la norme devait le vecteur
vitesse spatio temporelle de la voiture
c'est la norme du vecteur
un v
en utilisant la métrique 2000 koski on
obtient racine carrée de ces carrés fois
un au carré - v au carré
est ici en particulier on peut
factoriser par ces carrés on obtient ses
x racines de 1 - v carrés sur ces carrés
enfin on aimerait calculer les produits
scalaires de eu avec k et devait avec k
est pareil ces produits scalaires se
détermine à partir de la métrique le
produit scalaires entre huées cas est
donné par le produit scalaires entre 1,0
et alors car c'était un c'est
ça ça donne donc le produit scalaires
est donnée ici cc carré
x 1 x 1 donc x 1 - b x bêta donc zéro
fois ces mets ici 0 face et ça donne
zéro donc c'est simplement ses carnets
et pour terminer le produit scalaires
devait et cas c'est le produit scalaires
des vecteurs 1v et 1 c
et ça ça donne c'est carré x 1 x 1 ce
qui donne un - v x c'est
que l'on peut factoriser comme étant ses
carrés facteur de 1 - v sur ces
et voilà ici on a obtenu toutes ces
expressions qui sont toutes les normes
et les produits scolaires dont on a
besoin pour calculer la fréquence
d'émission et la fréquence de réception
de l'undd
alors la fréquence de réception de
l'ondh on a vu que c'était
une point qu'à / la norme de but donc eu
point casser ces carrés
et la norme de usc c est donc la
fréquence à laquelle est reçue londe
c'est simplement c'est alors vous allez
me dire la vitesse de la lumière c'est
une grandeur qui s'exprime en mètre par
seconde et la fréquence c'est une
grandeur qui s'exprime en hertz donc en
/ des seconds
ça ça vient du fait que nos vecteurs ici
une cas et v sont des vecteurs qu'ont
appris qu'on a choisi arbitrairement en
fait ces vecteurs n'ont pas vraiment de
sens physique et en particulier le
vecteur cas ici n'a pas vraiment de sens
physique la seule chose qui nous
importait c'était la direction des
vecteurs
et donc ça se traduit par le fait qu'
ici cette fréquence n'a pas vraiment de
sens physique non plus donc se sait ici
on peut pas vraiment l'interpréter tout
seul ce qui va compter c'est surtout le
rapport entre la fréquence reçues et la
fréquence à laquelle a été émise le
monde et c'est ça qui nous intéresse
c'est de savoir si l'ondh a été décalée
vers le rouge c'est à dire si sa
fréquence a été diminuée par le fait
qu'on observe en mouvement ou alors
décalé vers le bleu c'est à dire que sa
fréquence a été augmentée
est donc ici il faut éviter de chercher
une interprétation pour se sait on va
simplement calculer la fréquence à
laquelle est émise londe ici
et comparer les deux alors la fréquence
à laquelle est émise londe ces v
produits scalaires cas ça c'est carré
facteur de 1 - v / c
/ la norme de v
est la norme devait cesser x la racine
carrée de 1 - v carrés sur ses carnets
si on peut faire une simplification en
divisant en haut et en bas par c et on
peut remarquer
que ces deux choses là se factories
alors 1 - v sur ses racines de 1 - v sur
ces foires racines de en mauve est sûr c
est un - v carrés sur ces carrés on
reconnaît l'identité remarquable à
carrer moimbé carrés et à carré -
becquart et
peut-être factoriser comme a + b facteur
de 1 - b
si bien que cette racine ici peut-être
factoriser comme un plus v sur ces
facteurs de 1 - v / c'est
ici on peut annuler de ses racines et on
obtient finalement que la fréquence à
laquelle est émise l'aude est donné par
ces facteurs de racines de 1 - v sur ces
sur un plus vais sur scène
alors encore une fois ici se sait n'a
pas vraiment d'interprétations physique
mais par contre ce qui compte c'est
qu'on observe que les deux valeurs sont
différentes et donc que le rapport des
deux est différent de un essai ce
rapport là qui nous intéresse donc pour
terminer on peut écrire que la fréquence
à laquelle est reçue londe fr
cfe la fréquence à laquelle elle a été
émise par la voiture
/ ce terme ici cette racine carrée et
donc en fait x l' inverse c'est à dire
par la racine de 1 plus v sur ces sur 1
- v sur ces
et voilà et ça c'est la formule de
l'effet doppler relativiste c'est à dire
l'effet doppler dans le cas des ondes
lumineuses dans l'espace temps
alors en particulier on observe que la
formule est différente de ce qu'on avait
obtenu dans le cas classique pour des
ondes sonores on avait obtenu cette
formule là
et cette formule là on voit qu'elle est
différente ce qui indique bien que les
ondes lumineuses se comportent de façon
différente et la grosse différence en
fait c'est que ici il a formulé
parfaitement symétrique vous voyez que
si on inverse la formule c'est
équivalent donc si on inverse on obtient
1 - v sur ces sur un plus v / c est ce
assez équivalent avoir simplement
remplacé v par - v
c'est à dire en fait que le rapport
entre la fréquence reçues et la
fréquence émises
s'inverse lorsqu'on passe du référentiel
de l'observateur au référentiel de la
voiture les deux référentiels sont
parfaitement symétrique et équivalents
ce qui est faux en dans le cas des ondes
sonores pour des ondes classique parce
que ces ondes se propage dans un
référentiel privilégiés qui est celui de
l'air